I'm Eric Mason I'm a mother and I'm a
transgender guy Koree is my 15 year old
transgender daughter I started
transitioning almost two years ago and
Corey started transitioning almost five
years ago I've always known that I was
different I've always known that I'm not
been normal boy I was never like happy I
was always negative when I first found
makeup I would like my family is made up
of me my husband and my five children I
waited until Cory was completely through
her transition before I came out myself
it was really hard keeping that secret
from my family especially for my husband
but at the time I just knew I had to
focus on my child I was invited to fifth
grade and I was in boys in there when
kids said us you go and kill myself
because sit I was different
[Music]
when my mom came out I was like I'm not
alone anymore we can actually understand
what we're going through with each other
we can no talk to each other for having
a bad day me supporting Cory is in my
opinion what you're supposed to do as a
parent you're supposed to support your
children no matter what so I don't feel
like I did anything special I didn't I
just love my kid I love my kid no matter
what she looks like no matter who she
wants to be we are stronger as a family
I think anytime you are living your
authentic self and you are living your
truth it makes you a better person
overall it makes you a better parent and
make sure better spouse my family is
everything
we fight we laugh we cry we're a typical
family we just look a little different
that's it it's all boils down to
[Music]
you